if one thing has become clear during the
course of this pandemic it's that
our leaders simply don't care at all
about the well-being and welfare of the
people they're supposed to represent and
lead
and it's not that they hate us you hear
that a lot oh they they hate us no
hatred
would require a passion that they don't
possess it would mean that they
care if in the wrong way what we get
from washington instead is much more
banal
much emptier worse even
what we get is disregard indifference
neglect
and this is put it mildly not the
attitude you want from your lawmakers at
any time
and especially not at a time like this
it was easy to predict this you know in
hindsight or even in foresight
if you have a group of people in charge
who don't really care what happens to
you or your family
and also don't really care about the law
then the pandemic hits
what are they likely to do they're not
they're not just going to leave you
leave you to your own devices which
would have certainly been preferable
but they are you know they're they
aren't gonna do that because
they want to appear like they're doing
something also they realize that they're
being presented with a profound
opportunity to
seize more power and influence so
instead they
shut everything down tell you to stay
home tell your children to skip school
for a year
tell you not to visit your elderly
parents or let your children see their
friends
and then pat themselves on the back when
the numbers go down when the numbers go
up
as they have they will just blame you
for not listening to their instructions
no concern for your overall health and
well-being no concern for your quality
of life
no concern for your life at all no
concern for your child's education
none of that you're just a number a
statistic
what do they care how a statistic feels
why should they care about a number's
suffering
this dynamic was thrown into sharp
relief this week with the stimulus bill
that congress
came up with in a compromise now you
always know you're in trouble whenever
there's a bipartisan compromise
people always love bipartisan
compromises i don't
it's bad enough when one party has a bad
idea but when they both agree on a bad
idea
it has to be especially horrendous and
it is the bill 5000 pages long totaling
almost
a trillion dollars in spending would
among other things
many many other things which we'll get
to in a minute provide
600 checks to some americans
now some lawmakers have objected to this
portion including rand paul
who should be commended at least for
objecting at all but his objection might
miss the point
a little bit listen why stop at six
hundred dollars a person
why not a thousand dollars why not two
thousand dollars
maybe these new free money republicans
should join the
everybody gets a guaranteed income
caucus
why not twenty thousand a year for
everybody why not thirty thousand
if we can print up money with impunity
why not do it
the treasury can just keep printing the
money that is
until someone points out that the
emperor has no clothes
and that the dollar no longer has value
to so-called conservatives who are quick
to identify the socialism of democrats
if you vote for this spending montrosity
you are no better
when you vote to pass out free money you
lose your soul and you abandon forever
any semblance of moral or fiscal
integrity
now i agree that the government spends
too much and is spending too much in
this bill as always the trillion dollars
absurd
um but when it comes to the direct
payments to individuals there are two
ways of looking at it one
is that the federal government shouldn't
be giving anything to anybody in this
case
the states are the ones that have
imposed these lockdowns why should a
taxpayer in say north dakota
have to bail out a small business owner
in new york should new york do that it's
new york's fault
this line of thinking would lead to
congress spending zero dollars on direct
payments
the other line of thinking is that the
federal government is also
also responsible for pushing the
lockdowns especially through mouthpieces
like fauci and berks and
besides as this line of thinking would
go whoever is to blame the fact is that
millions of americans are in dire
straits through no fault of their own it
was public policy on whatever level
that brought us here we pay congress to
help solve problems like this
now they need to do their jobs but
that's going to require a lot more than
600
for the people who need it now place the
blame wherever you want the fact is that
the government
has shut down entire industries
prevented millions of people from going
to work
bankrupted businesses thrown families
into financial ruin and destitution
the government did this if the
government tells you that you aren't
allowed to go to work or that as a
business owner you aren't allowed to
serve customers
or you could only serve you know 30
percent of the of
of your customers the government is
taking from you and it owes you
restitution
compensation this isn't welfare this
isn't the normal sugar daddy routine
from the government this is about
americans
getting what they're actually owed
actually entitled to an entitlement in
the true sense of the word
the whole problem with what we normally
call entitlements
is precisely that the people getting
them are not entitled to them
in this case they are but the problem is
that 600
is an insult it's a slap in the face
it's worse than nothing it's the
equivalent of
on a smaller scale you know when i was
delivering pizzas as a teenager
and one time the customer was was mad
that his order was late not my fault by
the way
so he paid his bill and then pulled out
a nickel to hand it to me as a tip
he meant it as an insult and if it was
like 50 cents at least
maybe i would have taken it but even i
won't lower myself for a nickel
this is like that you know they're
tossing a nickel at the people
that they have bankrupted 600 may as
well be a nickel if you just lost your
business
or about to lose your house can't afford
food and so on if you have
say four thousand dollars of necessary
monthly spending including mortgage and
food and utilities and all that
car payment whatever 600 bucks isn't
better than nothing it is nothing it
gets you nowhere does nothing for you
and it gets worse the bill also includes
all sorts of goodies put in there by
various politicians for the sake of
their special interests
tom elliott with uh grabian media has a
good threat on this
let me read some of what he found in
this bill um
and this doesn't even begin to cover it
as the thing is again
5 000 pages long there is no good reason
for a piece of legislation to be 5 000
pages long
or even 100 pages or even 50 pages all
of those extra pages
give you stuff like this as elliott
documents quoting from his thread
says the coveted relief bill lays
groundwork for a climate security
advisory council
the cover relief bill also includes 10
million dollars for
gender programs in pakistan
not exactly sure what that even is the
covered relief bill sets aside funds to
investigate the 1908 springfield race
riot
the bill includes a lengthy subsection
titled the horse racing
integrity and safety act of 2020.
the bill creates a committee regulating
performance-enhancing drugs in horse
racing the bill outlays funds to address
gender inequality amongst statues not
sure that's
i think we need to read closer into that
one but this is this is just what he's
what he's come up with
the coveted relief bill includes funds
for a museum that will offer programming
education
exhibitions on the life art history and
culture of women
the cover relief bill includes 1.5
million for the appropriations
committee's
office of diversity and inclusion as
well as lots of money for receptions
and we could go on listing things again
5 000 pages
that's three copies of war and peace
stacked on top of each other and somehow
even more boring to read i'm sure
this is what we get our elected leaders
playing games
attending to their special interests
while millions of americans
plunge into destitution this should make
us all
there's a lot of cheap outrage out there
every day
over dumb things this is uh this is real
this is something that is really
outrageous that is really
worthy of our of our outrage well hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content